for the moment they're sticking to their
ground no renegotiation that's the line
that's been the firm line I mean the
prelude to all this Francine was it
about two weeks ago dish Spiegel
reported that Angela Merkel could live
and was making contingency planning for
a Greek exit from the euro now they
walked that report back a little bit
last night we got from the finance
ministry was a very clear line saying
the agreement reached with Greece
remains valid this morning all
throughout the morning talk shows also
local newspaper interviews there is a
great sort of emphasis being put on
Greece needing to stay with the bailout
program they're saying that they need to
continue to pay back debt and you look
at the bill this is sort of the
mass-market tabloid here they had a they
went big they went splash you with it
there's a great deal of concern and it
reflected in the German popular opinion
sixty-eight percent of Germans do not
favor opposed a debt restructuring build
is really whipping up the sort of
anti-austerity sentiment or anti
anti-austerity I should say and they're
really leading this charge it's going to
be interesting to see whether or not
Merkel and her finance ministry blue can
keep the German public with them or
webinar the German public will simply be
driving this and if the German public is
driving it it's going to be no
renegotiation no haircut no change in
mercurio charities there's a very hard
line it seems at least in the public
press Francine yeah and Hans what's the
ECB stance you just told us of course
what the German central bank yeah is
there any room for the ECB to act as
pressure valve if they you can't find a
political solution so what the EU has
said or this is this is mr. benoit core
he gave an interview at handelsbanken a
lot of these interviews take place in
German language media but his interview
and huncles but was saying there needs
to be a political solution that the ECB
even though they remember the troika the
ECB cannot by itself cancel or
restructure any of the debt that you
need to have it just be legally
impossible so the ECB at least Frankfurt
side of things is firmly putting the
ball back in Brussels
cord they of course have that finance
ministers meeting at three thirty today
and then in just a couple of hours
couple minutes really later on this hour
we'll get reaction from the German
government officially maybe we can tease
a little bit more out of them of what
they think about what this new coalition
government in Athens is going to look
like Francine all right Hans thank you
so much Hans Nichols there with the
German and deceive you reaction